[Music]  did you know that monopoly was designed  to teach people about the evils of  capitalism  left-wing activist lizzie maggie  patented the landlord's game in 1904.  it had two sets of rules the monopolist  rules  which worked like the game we know today  and the prosperity rules  where every player got a piece of money  from rent  not just the person who owns it the  point was to play both versions to learn  how all members of society could prosper  with a more equal system  instead of one greedy person hoarding  all the wealth and leaving  everyone else bankrupt parker brothers  bought maggie's patent for just  five hundred dollars maggie hoped they'd  spread her anti-capitalist message  instead they spread only the monopolist  message that stockpiling money is  somehow a good  thing so the next time you hand over  your remaining monopoly bucks to your  buddy with a hotel on park place  remember capitalist greed only helps the  few  on top and leaves everyone else behind  you